what's up everyone welcome to GameSpot
live we are back it is Tuesday Tuesday
yes
Tuesday and then we're gonna have two
streams today actually because there's
just a lot going on
we're extorting off with the overwatch
and then later in the afternoon we're
gonna come back and play some of the
division two because they also have a
new update so I mean we had to kick it
off with some overwatch though the brand
new Sigma ya Sigma he is like a thing
now and PTR he's live on the PTR I'm PC
that is what we are playing on today by
the way I'm pressure this is David do
this in case you guys didn't already
know
um but yeah he doesn't really have any
skins or anything right now but you have
to look at him and before I even say
anything I'm gonna let you guys take a
second to just like digest this what's
up everyone in chat high-crime welcome
back and everyone else tuning in
but yeah Sigma is here this is 90
doesn't have any any skins or nothing
that we can show off just yet
but he is in PTR and his feet are out
there like everything else on his body
is covered except for his face and its
feet it's it's something man it's a
sight I really got a you really got to
kind of take it in and look at this like
knock off lex luthor right this frickin
bandaged feet so you know we're thinking
we're gonna pop them into training mom
real quick just so you guys can get a
peek at all of his abilities because you
know how it is out there might be a
little difficult snagging
game although I think we're gonna run
the no-limits mode a couple times silver
at least guaranteed to see them but you
know it's going to be me so yeah
touji offensive I can't with you guys
it's he's gonna stop his toe it's true
he's got some interesting news he like
he's got this weird portal he was kind
of shoots out these like old driving
balls and he never runs out it's like an
infinite right and because it's a tank
he's got a really cool thing where he
shoots out a little barrier right but
the interesting thing about this barrier
is he can remove it whenever he wants he
can put it out whenever he wants remove
it whenever he wants there is no
cooldown and here's the coolest part you
can choose how far you want the barrier
to go you know that's cool by recasting
it right yeah yeah you hold down the
right clip and then you let go and it's
super cool so if you got like a choke
point and you want your crew to rush you
just [ __ ] and you push that that's
pretty cool
and he's got this like how much health
official fifteen hundred oh that's
pretty good
fifteen hundred from the beginning and
then it just kind of winds down but
you've got on this other move where he
like yeah that's that's I'm down with
that
that's got a pretty big cover but I'm
not sure what the shift one did a little
portal and wonderfully oh it did take
something that's tight
I wonder what let me act I think should
be able to pull up all this I'm just
gonna keep shooting some bots wait shoot
you're like basic attack at the wall
[Laughter]
we're breaking the game right now
thanks yeah signal launches to pronounce
gravity pathetic I don't know rabbinic
charges which bounced off walls and
implode after a shot short duration
damaging enemies within a sizeable
radius ok so there's actually debris oh
sure okay let's see experimental Barry
error Sigma propels a floating variate
area location of his choosing okay right
and then the other one is kinetic grasp
Sigma freezes incoming projectiles in
midair converting them into shields into
shields so like so he'll regenerate or
something
maybe but I mean I know it absorbs the
bullets the very least which is very
clutch if you got that soldier all kind
of you know peeling on he's done let's
check out his big big ol oh yeah for
sure it's not like that same radius
except you get to like float around so
it's a mixture of doom fist and Zarya
like all combined together and you just
let's see it unleashing his full power
Sigma takes flight lifts enemies in a
targeted area and launches them into the
sky before slamming them back down that
is the official description of his hero
31 and the 10th new hero added to this a
lot of heroes I think he's like man they
gotta change the character selection cuz
it's when you actually hit someone
directly it bounces off of them do
so can you like you know bounce it off
of - yeah like of to be or nice to show
you like yeah I'm interested to see what
his so the team can shoot him on water
in the air and then drops them back down
to some like finishing damage that
[Music]
yeah let's let's put him in action all
year on vacation Hanzo is relaxing right
now he's loving life
[Music]
alright cool yeah so we're gonna do this
6v6 No Limits because we already know
it's gonna be him trying to get Sigma
right now and in a regular game so yeah
should be good use it properly this time
guys and we did it we did it we used to
be indoors for one we just did this
little gravity well indoors and it'll be
it'll be fun there's like a 7.1
earthquake in California we'll we'll try
and top that don't even remind me I was
like in the 24th floor of a building
like swings you know they're designed to
do that to withstand earthquakes it's
just a weird feeling it's weird but we
have a couple people think he's he's in
PTR yeah oh yeah yes we are on PTR we're
on PC so if you go to the PTR server on
over watching your Blizzard app and
update it you will have access to yo boy
Sigma yeah boy Sigma what up guys smash
that sub button someone said can you
explain his ultimate again sure yes it
is called gravitic flux is that the
proper way to pronounce
gribbet gravity I don't know her physics
Lex I'm just gonna call it gravity flux
because that just sounds easier for me
um anyways unleashing his full of power
as Sigma takes flight lifts his enemies
in a targeted area and launches them
into the sky before slamming them down
so one thing I actually didn't like did
you go into the air when you lifted it I
did okay interesting were you able to
shoe or do anything while they were oh
you're in oh so you just got like the
little zone and you kind of choose the
zone around look at all their feet that
is just yeah we have the pole suit of
armor but the toes man and our toes are
like our most fragile points of our body
you can't walk without your big toes
like toes in danger it's gonna be so
what does his II do so his II kind of
like pulls up the ground and then throws
the rocks at the enemy so hello hello
yeah he's pretty proper I did see some
people in the chat saying that his voice
actor was Judge
oh look at all these shields going this
is heaven this is and it's amazing
so the barrier does have a recharge once
it gets destroyed yeah
yeah all these they have one on I love
oh yeah chat wants to see what is mainly
looks just Mele it's playing again if
you yeah that would be great you just
see those little toes then we've got
different key lines on this keyboard off
and see what is
yeah to ago I can imagine how insane
that's gonna look in a teamfight be PES
with everyone having all the shields and
stuff like that like the ERISA you know
when you have like ERISA shields out and
all of their shields out so be able to
list the team above the shield that's
nonchalant man at the skin
[Music]
we took a look earlier it's only all of
the basics up right now on the PTR but
I'm sure once he's actually out he'll
have all that good stuff
yes Josh Tate this is indeed the PTR
daddy lands us this Anna hates fun yeah
the passive is no footsteps because he
has controlled gravity he's got like a
magneto essence floating noise
he's like rolling dice yeah I wish he
had three and they need to be like an
avatar in their offender and he's had
the little rocks and stuff favorite team
is health regenerate his shields
regenerate his help does not but his
shields were generated and you can't
help his fields regenerating by doing
the
if you're old oh I do idea
that's funny good time to use it so yeah
technically has a little bit ever
regenerate but it's for the shields and
so hey that's still really good though
it's like 25% of it maybe so we will
oh my god there's so many shields
everywhere anyway they're all tink so
it's like no one's quite dying yet yeah
oh let's see if I can flank them and
pull out a
you didn't go up that high
I didn't I kind of liked all that I
don't know obviously I think you like do
a little levitation when he has this
shield in front of him like bounce your
grenades off the kind of food does
damage he absorbs go to your shield that
you have al or just see you yourself
it's a good question I don't know I have
to try that as well experimenting 50
billion people says you just know he's
gonna get a skin that turns his orb
things into dice he has yeah yeah yeah
for sure he has to strike you should be
like a poker dealer or like a casino
dealer and skin
that's some good damage get wait yeah
see like what you should do about that
now she didn't think about this use
those ricochet powers David
ricochets kind of that's some like stuff
with someone that is awesome someone's
had planned mode that's less hectic
we're chosen so that we can at least
guarantee to get the champion but in a
few we're definitely gonna try to get
him try some quick play stuff yeah crime
says this week's goals every week I make
small goals like kind of motivate not so
I don't know if you guys heard but Red
Bull conquest has been announced and
that is gonna be going on from August
24th to November 24th and it's got
street fighter ii and unis so this
week's goal is to do some studying and
get some practice in I kind of miss
playing my fighting games you know I've
been playing a lot of stuff and a lot of
not fighting in so I'm really excited
for that so yeah that's my goals this
week play some fighting games there's
some great goals brush up you know
there's some really good goals play of
the game
Sigma yeah we're gonna see that a lot if
the khana got the play of the game
something interesting wait so he was
floating pretty high up so you must be
able to control like your spacebar cool
Natasha he is cool he is for sure
dungeon master skin with 20 sided dices
would be awesome yeah we call they're
usually very creative with their skins
especially one like the seasonal stuff
that they do we kind of interested to
see what they do for him for like the
winter once they get like icicles like
sticking out of his shoulder pads yeah
the Pharaoh winter skin is one of my
favorites Oh variety okay oh snap I got
a May we got my little hamster boy name
is BAE Mays BAE that is correct
yeah awesome didn't you I cosplay
I remember now yeah yeah you kicked ass
that was awesome awesome first cosplay
ever oh they got a tracer check they're
a rock at yes
number chuckling pick no skins so far
that is true Casper Anderson we
definitely that was like the first thing
we did we went to go look at skins and
stuff
it's like hard to throw a rocket like
force yeah yeah okay Matthew says FYI
all does 50% of the affected characters
max HP is that HP that they currently
have our HP in full because that's yeah
well it was actually killing people so
it must be HP in full because it was HP
that currently has and you wouldn't even
kill anybody
it's so nice cool oh and absorbing
shields adds to his HP being all a
doofus or wrecking ball well thanks for
the pro tip be here rolling the date
nice
I can just only really think the :
like gamma William right right well okay
really I get those angles down you would
see maybe it's right like some ceiling
action then you could do some cool think
he's really he's really interesting
because you have a lot of new characters
in recent time that yeah kind of had a
high ceiling
and a high floor like it took some time
to really good used to them yeah he's
definitely point the boys is the boulder
tossing a single target
and asks mr. it looks like it just hits
like the first target it runs into yeah
yeah it goes a little bolder from the
ground or whatever
yeah for sure no wait to see in there
and then we're gonna guess it's the
perfect moment you have a shield for
like every door on this yeah we'll
definitely attempt to play a normal yeah
it doesn't really seem like he has much
of an escape mm-hmm his mobility is
obviously a little bit slow so really
does make another yeah just gotta know
when your shields up the one you need to
absorb
I guess the absorb is kind of the escape
only in terms of like in dis absorb
stuff
yeah can you jump up you're funny a
little bit yeah yeah gotta get that
Roman shield
doing else having more to when I they
guy cookies down as well
this boy yeah I think ultimate wombo
combo would be like Zarya group muff and
then you to levitate them and then doom
fist and you're all together to slam
them down that's like ultimate wombo
combo
no there's just so many possibilities
just walk right into it what the heck
make them
we have like a they have a gamma wave we
have a healer now yes nice so if I
disable it I think the shields will
regen but if the shield is odd yeah even
if you reuse it so like if it gets
damaged I like 1300 and I get rid of it
when I put it up again yeah this is just
like it's just a prison like waiting
that they all project that yeah yes I
guess with good shield management you'll
just always have it there's also no
cooldown right
you know people really will like play
like two minutes of the care can be like
all right switchin Asst for me yeah they
know pretty soon I wonder what his
interactions with other talent and
overwatch members are that's a very good
question
right cuz his back story is pretty
interesting villain who's not
technically a hero he's mr. bad boy
which is also insert interesting like
who else do we have in the cast right
now that's like as villainy as him
that's a good point like I felt like
he's definitely the darkest like
character we've had mm-hmm
all right let's try to do it going into
the let's try to is the shield like
Symetra sold shields um I would kind of
but Symetra sold shield you couldn't
control right it would right just goes
out yeah we just kind of go yeah I don't
know I I would say it's more like IRISA
but you can decide where you want to put
it it doesn't just go in one spot mm-hmm
it's pretty interesting it's like and
and you can control it by holding it
down the longer you hold it down the
further away it goes it floats in the
air which I thought was really
interesting to you yeah um I think he's
gonna be a technical character between
you know learning how to place his
shields making good use of his auto
attack because it's icy I'm playing too
many games right now yeah cuz they bring
caches I think it's really cool it's
like the brute shot from Halo if you
guys remember that gun
a sigma villain
yes he is definitely kind of got a few
screws loose and I think he does work
with talent right like officially he's
part of he's like a new member of talent
or something like that lore why so they
like control him here we'll read you
guys the story from overwatch Gamma
pedia so you know it's official
brilliant astrophysicists dr. Sebring
dick Cooper oh man this is already a
mistake his life's changed forever when
an experiment gone wrong gave him the
ability to control gravity now Talon
manipulates him to their own ends
dr. Cooper was considered a pioneer in
his field his life's work involved
devising a way to harness the power of
gravity equally known for his
groundbreaking research in eccentric
personality he conducted most of his
studies from his lab in the hog yeah
yeah Haig our God is I hate I hate it I
don't know how it sounds
believing that he was close to achieving
his goal he performed his most important
experiment on an International Space
Station oh snap but something went wrong
triggering the brief formation of a
black hole
dr. Cooper was only exposed to its power
for a moment but he suffered serious
psychological damage the area around him
began to experience strange fluctuations
in gravity peaking and dropping in time
with his reactions he had to be
evacuated immediately upon returning to
earth dr. Cooper was quarantined in a
secret government facility between his
ravings about the patterns of the
universe the psychic damage he sustained
and the grow vidiq is that how you
pronounce like gravity good NAM anomaly
is happening around him he was deemed
unsafe and detained for years under the
name subject Sigma isolated and unable
to control his powers dr. Cooper
retreated into his own mind he thought
he would never see the outside world
again when Talan discovered dr. Cooper's
existence they infiltrated the facility
and broke him out
uses brilliance and research to further
their plans in their custody dr. Cooper
slowly gain control of his powers and
now gravity moved according to his will
and he was closer than ever to achieving
his life's goal but the same experiment
that had opened his mind had also
fractured it and he struggled to keep
the pieces together
dr. Cooper continues to develop his
powers in hopes of unlocking the secrets
of the universe unaware that Talyn is
using both him and his research done
today and we didn't find a match in that
entire time I mean everyone's gonna be
trying to fit the role for being a tank
man it's just gonna be I know everyone
wants to use him like what do we do did
we go back to 6v6 probably we can give
it another like 45 seconds let it hit
the five-minute mark and then just oh
yeah I was hoping during that story at
some point we'd have a match but we got
to read it on set and if you guys saw
the little trailer video it was also
pretty interesting the trailer was nuts
it was really real interesting there was
a lot of crazy like jump cuts and you
know sort of fourth wall breaking stuff
and reality bending things I mean our
boy Sigma with his bandaged feet he's
got some mercy man says fYI Chi prayer
is pronounced hyper because I just read
that before I said it
not a knock Cooper or Cooper Thank You
Marissa man thank you
yeah I was like I know I'm
mispronouncing it cuz you know I only
speak English unfortunately I took it on
me once in college and there's the
Kuiper belt so I should have known it's
kind of you know interesting rip that
you want to just try the new limits yeah
let's go back to new limits or some
other arcane boom mode where we might
get him
it's Oh
it's back to chaos folks this is what we
this is what we do here at GameSpot we
utter Sigma chaos but today's cool
because we have another stream ya
Division two you guys they also drop
some hot new dlc episode 1 the DC
outskirts we're gonna be checking that
out later on today 2 p.m. um so if you
want to stick around wow we are just not
having any luck now finding any matches
what's going on here you want to see
some soup yeah if you play Sigma's
trailer backwards you'll hear a few
words really
Derwin gamer I said that in the chat and
now I'm like really interested you
remember they used to like play a bunch
of people's songs backwards back in the
day trying to like decipher his secret
code or they'd be like this bands
worship all beetles you do it backward
and everyone was saying like oh yeah
this makes me feel old the youngins
don't know about the beetles come on
what do you mean about those insects
yeah they fly around and oh we got a
widow ok wait I got 5 Sigma's and a
widow that sounds like a sitcom do you
that widows gonna have a very tough time
trying to get some shots with all their
shields oh yeah you're right you're
right I was like it might be easy unless
she goes up up top somewhere it's like a
pro would alright but it did look like
you could look into the air and throw
your shield like look up straight up and
throw it yeah you know doesn't matter
where you are yeah just hold this flat
screen relic lay pretty cool
wonder how far could go like if you just
have like a straight line just just keep
going until it like hits something
wow that they go pretty far you didn't
stop it that time rate just goes yeah
yeah it's going it's going
it didn't stop or is it still going
right you could barely see it that's so
funny that was it seems like once it
once it hits a yeah so it goes until it
makes contact yeah I like there's a
little bit of pushback I mean you are
getting smacked
filled up there it seems like yeah oh my
goodness good thing you can only pick
one champion in a regular game because
so when he does his normal attack it
automatically throws both with the dice
mm-hmm it's not what they're called but
you know what that's what we're gonna
call them yeah
forget like gravity well is there
anything just call dice ricochet action
wonderful that might be my favorite
thing about it so far
ricochets that has some good uses
although it doesn't seem like it does
not manage except I can't really tell
because like all tanks right and all
shields right right that uh that's
number that they have is kind of give me
problematic because I think I think you
know there's so many just like no fun
police characters here where they just
want to want to take away your ability
and risk so thanks guys he'd straight
the moon now we protected oh we sent the
shield up for the haunted haunted by
aliens
oh my gosh
but now that's siphoning like my hell
yeah
no miss family I really wish we could
like see how he is in a normal game even
if we're not using him because I just
think it's gonna be like it's one thing
that play him in something like this I
don't think we can actually get a feel
for how well he fits in like a team
comes in this type of shirt literature I
could um yeah for this round I could
like just load it as like a normal DPS
or something and just like you know
stick to the Sigma's hip and follow him
around and see how he see how he does we
can play the role of just being very
judgmental
whoever poor guy ends up being sick
that's interesting that he can jump
without his evening yeah that takes some
he controls gravity yeah he does awesome
he controls it so well that you can jump
which is actually like I don't even
think you know a part of the controlling
gravity that you just float forever into
the sky
it really does look like
so that Maura is a very good counter
because it goes through yeah that's what
it's a lot of shields in this game
though there has to be somebody
yeah it looks like do decent amount of
damage I feel like you've been a mix of
a bunch of different heroes they can
Marvel infinite they have Ultron Sigma
right like a mix obviously not this
Sigma yeah all the barriers activate all
the barriers so the Makri yeah no he's
getting tired of all these shields oh
snap by player kill Street yeah let's go
oh and the Moira was damaging you
through the two-year absorb also yeah
being ruff ruff oh no little section oh
we got a Moria not to yes calcio Sigma
is indeed a tank
oh yeah meleave high noon yeah what's
the high noon give me yeah there's
shields every wow he's like oh yeah
thank you
oh boy oh boy
so that's tough oh boy get your shield
bro you're not abusing this shield
enough it's as much as very weak knave
still alight dang that Moya
yeah so 6ms old he can basically like he
like Rises into air and he pulls up
everyone like in the radius of his all
into the sky and then you know your
team's supposed to go ham on them while
they're loading and then he slams him
down and does more I kind of feel like
he is like space version of Reinhard
like a brain heart was that was a
astronaut he was a spaceman because
someone in the chat ultra also mentioned
and risk Cofield so the best way I can
see the strategy writing is maybe he's
being a defense guy someone's giving him
constant health and then someone going
forth in attacking and that's pretty
much like what you cube was riding on
all the time too
Oh snuck in someone else's Savin old
right
if only the answers were simple
now I didn't get the pun crime sorry
that one went over my head
what's up instinct welcome to the
channel we're chillin playing some Sigma
on the overwatch PTR look at all of
those look at all this totally boys let
all those toes no of course Moyer I got
those everyone man it's like there's a
very good counter to this tank yeah see
it's going right through doesn't even
matter
alright let's uh you want to you know
once again er do you want to try and
scout yeah let's see if we can get a
regular quick play not as a sank right
yeah we could try it one time it says
less than a minute but that's a laugh
that is a lot it's because everyone's
searching in tank maybe search oh yeah
these are tuned DPS or something it will
probably be fine but we'll give it a
shot one more time maybe it says less
than a minute so if we go past a minute
I mean while Zane says how is his origin
story animation and the origin story
animation was very good yeah I liked it
a lot it is up on gamespot.com if you
want to check it out yeah good where was
it on the trailer channel main channel
any channel on the web because that's
where I saw it right right
the Moriya counter seems good crime you
are correct it is good and it is really
good because I got to see it when we had
our Maura on our team and I was also on
the receiving end of it on the enemy
Maura it'sit's pretty good more that's
pretty pretty dope I think a lot of
people don't use her healing abilities
as much as they should though they tend
to use her as like in attacking support
character which is kind of an oxymoron
dude I really think the wave is like not
going for direct shots with his you know
basic attack because using you all the
time because it says after it bounces
off the walls it'll implode after a
short duration so it doesn't matter if
it like makes contact or not it'll
explode after it bounced off the walls
and then there's a radius of damage it's
not just the actual you know ball itself
so maybe like shooting at the ground
first in front of them is often totally
oh we got it let's go noise rapid monkey
goes how many games bought channels do
we have we've got yeah we've got a good
amount and you should subscribe to all
of them that's like my favorite like
youtuber joke lines yeah yeah like and
subscribe button I'm just gonna you know
end up breaking your keyboard because
you're just so in the Smashing that like
yeah thank you let's click right click
and then smash yeah hold third but
it's a method feed twice I mean I feel
like if it actually hits the person that
will just explode right like it won't
bounce off their legs
yeah Lucio Lucio load SPG's now let's
get that shield out and block sending
the shield to um what is that uh you
know there's too many characters in this
game that have the same names as epic
for sure I'm like you know when your
shield gets destroyed the cooldown is
very fast
I noticed that it got destroyed and it
was back with the Mike by a second
oh man that Sheils awesome against a
ferret ooh it's like you can put it up
in the air and like huh man they really
love fields in the game I really do like
this yields better and better
yeah this is cool how much damage is
each shot deal um no idea yeah we're not
super sure but both of those connected
and that almost killed her so that
wasn't bad you're also really close I
don't know if there's a distance I'm
playing I'm playing like like a GPS how
old is Sigma I don't know but he's been
through some things like space was not
kind
yeah like he has all the right to be a
grumpy old man in my opinion don't be
about gravity yeah that sounds like it
was like podcast
grumpy about gravity smacked by someone
I
60 damage per ball says chat says Harry
Barnes thank you for the pro info
Erwin says he is 62 man you guys got all
the Snapple [ __ ] Snapple facts at a mall
it doesn't look like his little gamma
wave goes very far right
oh boy
that's all right we did we did up that
how do you pronounce his first name
Sebring sirens sirens a kid a hyper
receiver in the Dutch man wrecking ball
alt under the Sigma alt they'll get
finished off by the minds that could be
fun it would be cool if when you pick
them up and floated you could move them
somewhere and then slam fit that would
be hey it's PCR right there's still time
for them to add and change stuff let's
make that up and I think that would be
cool you know you pick everyone up and
then you know let's say wrecking balls
all those already over there to the left
and then you pick them and then throw
them on to wrecking balls all a lovebird
you guys don't want me to design game
they're good she's been broken I love it
so much fun like I would make his little
orbs feel like you can shoot one or you
can shoot them both at the same time I
see I played a little bit of junk rat on
console and five back into it I think
you could have a lot of fun with the
reflecting stuff but this is nice
just having like abnormal team comp
right you're not constantly being
barrage with like shields exactly that's
definitely a plus
yeah I mean yeah face is no joke let me
just throw that out there so the fact
that Sigma you know he was out there in
space and there we go all types of
messed up pink you know
yeah things you're getting lit up by
somebody little more of someone else the
way his shield works so far I think the
shield is nice
chat is so funny Wow so basically is
primary weapon is infinity yeah yeah
yeah there you go there you go so great
I love it
I kind of feel like I would like to see
him with a mobility option like even
Reinhard has his like little charge
which is obviously not meant to view for
mobility but you can use it from our
village she'll too far and what else
like a big I mean I guess Aria doesn't
really have the brakes a mobility option
but no she has her barrier which can
help her get away a little bit
she doesn't need mobility so she's a
strong independent woman yeah oh yeah
sure
that shields broski you're good around a
little bit
oh dang like jumps up there and then
immediately got lit up that morning yeah
I said something Moyer is probably the
best healer
nice okay okay I feel better and we
survived I was like up in the air just
like technically giving mobility but
it's like you can't move left or right
when you're up there Erica yeah you can
you can got a bigger house nice flight
went higher up into the air yeah yeah Oh
or was it that's no what's that your
team's diva or was that was the other
teams told us the other teams yeah you
heard me play through the shield down
right inside let's go
ah man wanted a Sigma play of the game
no oh that was when I want to miss one
with me right there
Sigma looks like a cross between Lex
Luthor and that guy from Despicable Me
hanging above the brew group definitely
got like the most massive upper body
ever and the tiniest little legs looks
exactly like the fish skins very nice
they're happier back there like finally
yeah I know someone mentioned they
wanted to see signal one more time the
hero gallery real quick he does look
like grew in the face a little bit yeah
yeah that's a good point if you do the
it's the nose he's a classy too was he
playing a violin there like who's that
he had a little hand motions yeah it's
like a little moisture all right
he's class he just pulls out the dice
all right we found a match
success magneto and Doctor Doom I like
those references for sure yeah I
definitely he's got that magneto Eska by
when he's floating around yeah he's like
magneto and Farah and grew and like
Winston just for the toes but even
Winston and you know I think he's a
little bit more respectful with the feet
yeah I mean it's yeah it works right
this guy's kind of like it's so out of
left field he's very very funny what's
his email um I don't think he has any
emotes yet because it's like PT our
selves other besides if you just you
know we'd have to see up we're going
back to the back to the secret of the
secret wallpaper oh you know what else
would be cool with us all like if you
could pick up everyone in the circle so
you could also maybe save your teammates
pick up your teammates and move them
somewhere else yeah that's if you could
move people with your I'm still on this
crazy idea that doesn't exist
I'm just theory biting in my head I am
that's a really good point yeah yeah
that would be really cool you just take
him and you move into safety right you
know even if there maybe there's like a
wall or something in between they can't
get around you just right you throw the
shield down pick up your homies throw
them behind you very very good
but yeah they've definitely done a good
job at like making all the characters at
least different like in backstory and
like in the way that they function right
like they're familiar but they're also
different right because they have
elements of each other for sure for sure
who can counter him says Haley well
we're a big deal so we would probably be
good maybe a junk rock because he'd
shoot his you know navigate around the
thing out for sure I would say that
maybe amanda says he should wear shoes
and I agree you should also wear shoes
but he's he's also kind of just showing
off right like yeah like I could float
and I float so well that doesn't even
need shoes he's never get dirty I
control gravity oh he does have some
very pristine looking feet though I must
say it's just a pristine individual
probably a little jealous I wish my feet
I'm sure I'm thinking who else could it
could probably counter him cuz you would
think someone with proper range but even
then as we showed we were able to
counter that that Farah
right for a brief moment he L says why
would the people be similar well you
know like in other games probably like
fighting games more so some characters
are similar in style like show toes
they'll all have like a fireball a Tatsu
a DP you know stuff like that so
sometimes you know some characters will
be similar but that's why I think
overwatch pretty good at like keeping
their characters nice and varied yeah
for sure Reaper as a good
maybe says fluff raised 14 yeah if you
can get to him for sure I was gonna say
tracer because you could just bug him
right you just keep kind of back lining
and you're like again G or something
like that I wants it they're really good
at doing the the Ricochet dice throwing
because then with those types of
characters your HP is kind of low mm-hmm
yeah yeah he can't absorb projectiles
though which is has been kind of useful
didn't work on Moira though she was
going through that so she's definitely
seeming like a hard counter right Farah
against he was bad says crime but at
least he can put his shield up like in
the sky too and in her face yeah yeah I
felt bad for that Farah though there was
I usually have a very tough time
fighting fair but that Farah was bad
Haley says how are you guys finding the
role select is it effective I think it
probably is very effective except right
now everyone's probably searching in
tank looking to play Sigma yeah it seems
like why don't we I mean out to you but
maybe if we if I go in as a support and
I pick Moira and try to just yeah you
know counter some sense let's counter
what's harass there there signal yeah
because there's guaranteed gonna be a
Sigma Oh Sombra is definitely encounter
we saw that when we were playing the No
Limits we had all of these Sigma's and
then somber just came in and hacked
everyone we were all useless
Azaria a huge counter I'm not sure you
we didn't really like face off against
one just yet but damn it
Oh someone already had our idea okay
we'll see Baptiste just do it there's
like DPS healer so you said you played
soldier seems like a natural for Sherri
for sure um but yeah it definitely
Moira's up there is hard counter so far
more is yeah more is a good one in there
what about Symetra does her beam go
through because
so yeah it's a good point you know I I
don't know but I'm also very unfamiliar
with the Symetra that they kind of
revamped this like last year where they
changed her entire old and changed the
way that her like kind of abilities were
behaving right but there wasn't an enemy
Symetra but she didn't seem to do much
against us I definitely kind of think of
Moira and sombras like really really
hard counters that would be a total
nightmare yeah some of the other
characters we mentioned at least Sigma
does have some options like against
those like for example junk right stuff
like that but yeah Moyer y'all so it's
roll lock gonna be in quick play as well
I'm not a hundred percent sure it's
definitely up on the PTR right now
though my mean you know it's kind of
tough but I like a lot of different
characters in this game so I I don't
think I've settled on just like the one
character as my mean but
you play a lot of Zarya a lot about
peace I love me some junk rat also junk
that's fun like Chuck stuff and go him
and whatever he's fun
junk rats a lot of fun you should be
able to counter the signal with the junk
pretty well too I would think he use his
uh his rebound ability against them yeah
I think that piece of my favorite healer
right now
lucio used to be my favorite healer he's
fun I just like bleeping people off the
map to big people
where is this cheap
this is like the opposite of Sigma's
shield right like damage amplification
do they even have a Sigma right
oh there you I was like I haven't seen
ya so junk rats tired yeah that's kind
of what I want to know to like what is
the extent of how much Sigma can absorb
projectiles right is it all projectiles
for however long has it open there's a
cap at a certain you know level of
damage I wonder if I can find those
if it goes that in jeopardy he'll exist
yet
hey then she stabbed her Ashton says
it's like they made an anti overwatch
character well I mean I don't know he
seems pretty overwatching
like there's shield which I know is like
that's as overwatch as it can get a lot
of people called this game shield watch
I've heard that as a popular term really
yeah yeah I would say signal gameplay is
definitely a [ __ ] just like the
straight-up
defensive you know straight and narrow
style he's got a shield he's got an
absorb and then but it's almost like
with this design any bit more and bpop
yeah there's a limit for sure if he was
any faster he might be you know pretty
cheap if he did any more damage it would
probably be also pretty cheap I don't
know but this is PTR after all you guys
it's all good
it almost feels like the Sigma shield
looks bigger in certain places than
other it looks like it looks really tall
right now yeah od
nice Oh rip T me yeah
oh nice got some diva means in the house
because fun he was fun although before
they nerfed her her little shield
she definitely frustrated me to no end
so much so that I started using her and
then they nerfed her and I was like of
course the second eyes are amazing her
is when you decide that you want an
earthen you know the um always my sister
really loves Deva and there was that one
emoji has where she's like playing video
games I'm like even though I don't know
what it was but she's like drinking coke
I'm like eating like popcorn or
something absolutely love divas whole
persona I have a diva methanol Oh name
on my desk guy changes color when it
gets up should we put like tier
communist noise very cool Jack the
Ripper yes Sigma is indeed on PTR right
now we got a couple of games with him
right now we're just trying to see how Z
settings
we're in quick play trying out role
selection been pretty chill so far
thanks for joining us Joe cool
he said I've heard Reinhardt got nerve
and the PTR is that true
I actually have not heard anything about
that
and I haven't seen anyone play Reinhart
yes
yep so I'm not sure
duck 5:03 sighs I love your videos well
thanks we love you Oh fire at will
the old place heals way the Christian
that would be so cool if we got Neil
deGrasse Tyson to play over why that's a
great idea I need to pitch that to
someone heck yeah
or have like you know people in their
respective professions like talks about
how accurate a character is right like
we have Sigma and then we get a Neil
deGrasse Tyson Simon like break down his
backstory and be like yeah that's like
possible or not possible that's so great
Tyson such a good guy yeah he's down
with the times he makes science man bill
nice timeless he's like definitely
adapted to the era also so funny
I actually don't know if this is 100%
factual but I heard top tosh point-o was
Bill Nye son no and if that is actually
factual that is but I don't know oh the
chat is asking what is on your shirt
what is on my shirt so these are the
characters from Destiny on a break
where's the Destiny fans at do destiny
fans y'all got a lot to be excited for
I've been like slowly converting the
office into destiny fans well no I
didn't have anything to do with it they
they all kind of could just starting to
get interested in just the name
expansion there's gonna be a lot of fun
I cannot wait to stream with that
so Joseph says do you think he's cooler
lame do you think he needs buffs are
nerves and what do you think they should
change about Sigma okay so Sigma is cool
confirmed for me he's not lame he's very
cool um does he need a buffer a nerf
you know we need to be able to get into
proper like quick play rounds and where
we can have a nice team comp but I think
he is going to be fairly balanced when
people discover the proper counters
sembra I think you'll kind of be put
into check but any new character I feel
like become Sophie at the beginning you
know the shield is a little the shield's
kind of Oh P being able to instead of
getting used to like bringing it back
and throwing it out and holding it and
measuring how long you have to like hold
it forward to get it to the distance
that you want which are all just
technical things that'll take practice
right right but I think he'll be like a
good glue to any team he just needs a
little bit more mobility maybe he gets
some ability with his own but I think he
needs something more accessible but it
does have a lot of health and he has the
absorb which gives him you know the
armor back totally I guess it's just
give and take we're just gonna have to
wait and see how it plays out a little
bit longer it's literally like day one
early we got bellmen saying a couple
times that he's a big destiny fan oh I
see you dude bellman
science will reveal the truth man
you should hit up Sigma Morra I know and
not the account or dude that's why she
said she knows she knows she knows
science is the real truth exactly she
says hello warrior XL says is it true
that destiny is going freon in September
yes
cool yes it's it's that's totally true
and not just the base destiny game but
the curse of Osiris expansion and the
war mine expansion which I paid $100 for
you get to play free I'm a little
jealous but it's all good all right
oh dang the evidence suggests there is a
sniper
[Laughter]
thank you dr. Kuiper oh my god sorry I
am sorry Sigma hold this bad magic widow
she's questionable no div says I'm a god
Anna well that's awesome because analyte
think it's so hard to use that when I
say good and I'm like heck yeah you know
your stuff
this wrecking ball does not care about
anything as soon as you said they just
like comes out a second-story window on
the PTR easy right now like if you get
pinched by a wall I guess maybe or maybe
it's because I'm not like a tank of
character right
[Music]
I don't know maybe maybe stand by a wall
and try to get hit by it again unless
something else done to you but I'm
pretty sure it was that yeah for sure
interest no I think if you good if it
knocks you into a while like if it's
like vain right all right oh so you
killed him before the old finish so I
don't think it I think I am the people
down misty you're welcome teammates
oh snap
alright alright yeah Sigma come on
eventually need more EOP Wow it was
sleeping that was really good
taking a nap okay really napping on the
job an what I stand for it like public
test so it's basically a way for all of
us at home to kind of be able to test
new stuff so I think that's why they
choose to have it like on PC first it
was just easier to get things out and
you know testable one PC first before TT
cuz you know PC takes a lot of like
fine-tuning and small like detail work
between console and like coding and all
that stuff and approvals right right
so a lot of the time but you'll even
notice it in other games where updates
go out and you'll notice like one
console gets the update first and the
other one doesn't and that's less of
like a dev thing and
I know there's a freaking wrecking ball
such an annoying character he's a cute
Illinois
[Music]
public test realm thank you digital
Derrick that makes sense because
Blizzard has like reduce thank you login
to so I thought it might be a dude
hamster
sorry Vinnie
oh no oh nice okay noted people with
their escape often sing get out as usual
ooh and I'm done
this seems like the orb of a that he was
any orb that he gets is very helpful for
the Sigma did he used to own a hamster
yeah yes and she fits the heck out of me
like the first month I unders she was so
cute and I you know I was getting her
used to me and I would put like food in
my hands and she liked crawling in my
hand eat it and then one day I went like
ate dinner and like had some fried
chicken and like I didn't wash my hands
and I was like oh you know my hand and
she's like oh your hand smells like
chicken this big little plate out of my
finger and I was like ah I couldn't even
be mad at her though cause she's so cute
and it was like my fault like I should
have washed my hands properly before I
tried to feed her since that
doing animal things yeah smelled food
she ate it not her fault
however ham star here wreckingball he's
like all other Sigma is so unhygenic not
wearing any shoes
he's just floating those he doesn't have
the five-second rule on his feet because
he's never on the ground that's the real
text
[Music]
you got somebody my god does any
[Laughter]
villains don't need shoes bacteria
doesn't frighten me
oh no it's dangerous so I can out that
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to ask
the crime boys letting his feet breathe
after a long day some breathing room
please y'all don't know how stressful it
is man working for Talan
trying to you know trying to harness
grab think I do to get a do think he uh
yeah the Talon company guard doesn't
doesn't cover shoes so it's probably a
contractor Witter Dyess says which I
probably totally but your name why don't
they play as Sigma we played a couple of
games earlier we're trying out some
counter matchups against Sigma right now
just say you know get a feel for you
know who's missus and it's drinks I did
notice Moira we've really affected when
we were using it mmm-hmm so we're just
like further testing that out but yeah
we'll try to hop back into match with
him after this we just wanted you to
give it a try
totally and also see how he has a
character works as it you know a
teammate like does his shield
become very useful I don't know so far I
don't know if the shield is like super
super effective anymore than like a
running shield would be or something or
an erisa shield only because I think
people have not gotten 100% used to it
yet right I do see it out there but then
I just see it out there and that's it or
as like he can call it back instantly
throw it out again instantly there's no
cooldown unless it actually breaks wait
hold up okay nevermind nevermind that
was the impact hit you babe it looked
like he died - John crap yeah a junk rat
boosted by a IRISA and boosted by a
mercy he has to air out his athlete's
foot
sir this is a game spot okay nice we
have our Sigma right here next hey buddy
yeah his shield floats too which i think
is really cool like you put it anywhere
yeah that you are I can't stop looking
at him why do they stand out so much
it's a is it because they're like the
only things
King Aerys no socks huh
damn that's naughty but you know what
he's not wearing shoes so it's like
socks with no shoes that's like party
foul to the back yeah yo dude you miss
you right I don't know if you already
answered oh you guys come up with strats
for the new hero yet I mean right now we
kind of just been scoping him out in a
few different scenarios against him was
him on our team as him bounce absorb
yeah is that endgame wine rule was like
he's like she flipped the take names and
uh gas line from the one alien lady who
is with the guardians of the galaxy oh
yeah all right cool so we'll try to get
for the last game we'll try to get Sigma
alright so we're gonna try to hop back
in and get Sigma again yes um so yeah
pretty interesting I think we've
gathered a quite a bit of information so
far yeah yes this is DVD goon yeah goop
it's me your your long-lost friend I was
on I was on the stream with tape I was
like my first one a while back
that's when I met the the old classic
crime and goob
they're always it's always fun to see
them in chat yeah yeah
who would win in a race with Zen or
Sigma yeah they're both pretty floaty
I mean Zen gets style points I guess for
you know being meditated that's always
good but um but cigarette no I feel like
I guess Zen is more Zen pun intended
and then Sigma is just maybe he gets
points for being a bit of a brainiac
while he floats you know it's just
constantly grappling with the Kuiper
belt and gravity and everything hyper
hyper hyper beam high beam yeah hop in
man hop in PT yard see what Sigma's
about dog and then capture some extra
gameplay and then come work for GameSpot
everyone's searching tink right now and
roll select so we must wait what other
Snapple facts can I find on Sigma
internet inform me video though goober
human people were saying Sigma's weak
but it's not just about strength if you
watch carefully you can mix it with a
lot of other character this is what
separates overwatch from other
first-person shooters right in other FPS
if your god like nine times out of ten
you can at least carry the team enough
to win or get close to winning in this
game I feel like there's no amount of
carry that is good enough to be like a
one man versus everyone type of team
because you need you just need teammates
you need the healer and you need the
tank and you need the DPS everyone needs
to pull their weight it's crazy
unless if you're in bronze SR then you
probably need to get good unless
everyone is really really that bad on
the other team like it's really hard to
like one-man show
in this game totally totally and that's
the thing it's like you'd almost put
Sigma in like a tank support role right
not just like a straight-up tank like
like a Reinhardt would probably be where
he's just kind of there I feel like if
his absorb had like you know a small
radius around him like Lucio status and
it absorbed armor for everyone in your
radius including your cell he'd be like
brick and of that would be okay
but that would be cool maybe not a
radius as large as Lucio but right now
because people are gonna be next time
anyways if they're behind his shield
yeah so if they're that close and he
absorbs and he can bring back shields to
him in a squad a little bit more utility
they're sure you're not like a blizzard
spy hey help with some ideas I got some
they're all gonna be bad and impossible
to design but I've got them where do you
go to the PTR you um just go to your
battlenet you go to your battlenet on PC
only it's not on console and when you go
to overwatch you can select regions so
it would be North America Europe or Asia
and then you would just choose the wine
there's an extra one will say PTR then
you have to do an update it doesn't take
that long and voila if you have good
internet it was like a five point
something gig update you know in my
house that would take like an hour here
it took like two minutes yeah I would
only spoil the baby in this building
yeah oh man we are struggling to find a
match less than a minute yeah right
we could probably you know if we uh it
takes too long we could always just do
that no limits
chaos thing well I think you can select
all three roles and then you can just
try to race for you know make a race
towards Sigma okay so go back let's
select all three roles
let's try might find it fast you just
got a rush down Sigma where was it was
like right around here here we go oh my
goodness it also matters like how good
your oh they assigned you a random role
I was being smart
no I wasn't you want to do the arcade
yeah Julian Sigma's but we're also in
the last like five minutes of the stream
so yeah so we can we can send it out
with a huge twelve shield
you know what maverick calling us a
slowpoke to find a match you know it's
not our fault
maverick over there being a poopoo head
yeah it's not our fault everyone wants
to play Sigma all right we're trying
we're trying mister MAV pop Jones like
no match for you guys I'm gonna need you
to stop mr. Mathis is your real name
Sigma time we guaranteed housing for
segments are we gonna get all of them
yeah she's everywhere let's go zero e
limbs cuz there's so many shields I am
ready
this is gonna be the last game in the
stream also you guys make sure to tune
in though later today because we got the
division 2 episode number 1 busy
outskirts yeah we're gonna be playing
some of that 2 o'clock today division 2
at 2:00 on Tuesday I'm alright actually
we're gonna industry weather but yeah
we'll be back a little bit later on
today which is exciting more games to be
played
yeah Sigma Squad we got squad ma don't
worry guys dreams almost over okay squad
squad ma yeah huge signal encounters man
at the end of the day yep as everyone
just said Moira is my number one silver
a second and then any backliner
that has nice barrier synchronization
everyone would just be throwing them out
one at a time right that one broke but
it's all good it's no limit PTR is
madness I say never fashion Oh
team full of Sigma's and then one
counter she's gonna get her that's it
oh no just gang up on her yeah everyone
all aim for her
[Laughter]
right into the shield take that you
shield I feel like in this BTR it's
worth even just like breaking their
shield to you to force them to have to
like yeah but the rules of the recess so
fast it was like three or four seconds
or something like that he thought he
would get me with with that rock but my
shields just now with as many shields as
they do have a no mean they had that
about people that come it's nice to know
there is at least acknowledged
sure egg atomic says how do I play Sigma
well he has a shield as he conceives
many of them on the screen his auto
attack is like a brute shot from halo it
can also absorb projectiles and that
gives him fields as well and then he can
gamma wave you by pulling up the ground
and chucking it at people
and we think that if you hit someone
with a rock and it pins them against the
wall it's like where else can he even go
besides this choke plant right right
here just gonna end up one of these bad
boys here it's like do you use your old
just as a mobility thing Ziggy right oh
my god David I believe in you I believe
in you you can stand still in this cloud
I'm happy they'll never see us yeah I
did where I'm crouching now like we're
sneaking up on them they won't notice
you're an enemy thank you scratch it
that makes sense right
the Nemesis s didn't those origin video
kind of creeped out me and my father
yeah it was definitely very like weird
and like Yuri and dart kind of super
edgy whoo headshot we got our old now
though let's make it a good one let's do
uh let's sneak around and we'll do our
blending and then I'll just be like
surprise Sigma and ERISA sounds nice
yeah like you could throw her shield
somewhere and then you know sometimes
people like to throw their ERISA shield
on like the payload and that little gap
underneath like expose you you could
throw his shield underneath oh yeah
that's good yes Amanda he does have
origin vid
it's a short video of it's pretty good
that's pretty cool the origin yeah dog
food was very very good a lot let him
focus
nah I'm here to make divas life partners
did that damage them I mean I heard a
crunch if my damage on the way of if he
knock them in I don't know but that
sound effect was great
oh my god these headphones so good that
was very funny
panicky
stuff is gravity
say Yolo gaming says does he say any
Dutch - I'm touched by the way sure he
does but I did hear from the chat that
he is voiced by a Dutch voice actor so
that's pretty cool um usually with um
characters who are you know foreign they
do have their his sigma's nationality is
also - I see it on the Wikipedia here 62
years old yeah - boys limbal status
active someone should just Photoshop
Neil deGrasse Tyson said or maybe that
should be his like this legendary skin
boots you spread out it's gonna be a
what are your thoughts on on Sigma so
far though after see kind of like what
you do after seeing him in an in action
he needs I feel like he needs a
confident almost built around them to be
very effective for sure for sure I can't
see him being like a multi-purpose
yo talk about clutch this is you walk
onto the platform and then he just went
that's that's how we do it
alright let's see this play of the game
I need to see what it's yeah yeah yeah
it wasn't with an OL either
he found the prime opportunity where no
no yeah Hebrew shot it his way that was
the last place so good GG my friend yeah
so yeah I guess my thoughts on him so
far is that he's cool he's interesting
he looks technical he looks like he's
gonna take definitely some learning and
getting used to and then yeah he needs a
team that's gonna work with him well
someone who's gonna shut down like a
Moyra counter for sure yeah I'm
interested in seeing how everyone else
plays with them I'm I'm like curious to
see if I'm gonna change anything about
him after the PTR and I'm hoping we get
a costume with shoes yeah I would I
would like to see I would like to see
that his his feet covered up a little
bit yeah you know I say that all in fun
though like it's funny I think it gives
him a little bit of character or
something to like chuckle at as well
because he is like a serious and like
heavy character is something to laugh at
is nice but yeah hey sailboat I'm
noticing you alright everyone have a
good night and day wait actually come
back it to you because we're coming back
into we're gonna play some division two
and it's Tuesday and yeah we'll see you
guys later on today thanks for tuning in
we'll be Bob
good boy